I'm back in okay so I'm gonna pick up
where Jerome left off not sure if this
one's working I can just use this so
here's the matrix mechanism algorithm
that we ended with and in theory it's a
good algorithm but in practice we
haven't really been able to run it on
any like non-trivial problem and the
epsilon differential privacy regime so
now I'm going to talk about a related
algorithm inspired by the matrix
mechanism and it looks almost identical
but there's a few key differences that
allow you to scale up to much larger
domain sizes so the first key difference
is that the optimization algorithm that
underlies strategy selection is
different rather than trying to find a
globally optimal solution by solving a
expensive semi-definite program we try
to solve we try to locally optimize the
strategy by searching over a sort of
carefully parameterize space secondly
instead of representing the workload in
matrix form we use implicit
representations which are far more
compact but still allow you to perform
all the necessary computations of the
algorithm so these innovations you can
scale the matrix mechanism up to domains
of 1 billion so I'm gonna dive into the
optimization problem a little bit so the
space of all strategies is represented
by this blue region and optimizing
within that space is a hard problem but
if you careful if you like carve out a
region of the strategy space you can
carve out a region of the strategy space
where optimization becomes easier and
while the truly optimal strategy might
not lie in this space the hope is that
if it's expressive enough it might
contain something that's near optimal
I'll talk about one such region of the
strategy space which are the so called
the identity strategies so the basic
idea has given some parameters theta
there's a corresponding strategy matrix
a of theta which has the following
structure
so this is depicted in this matrix here
where the white cells of the matrix
correspond to structural zeros in the
strategy and the blue cells correspond
to weights that you can learn and this
parameterization was sort of carefully
designed to simplify matrix mechanism
optimization and so to optimize the
strategy of the swarm all we have to do
is find the best weights for these blue
cells so these types of strategies have
some nice properties by construction
they always have sensitivity 1 and also
it's always full rank so that sort of
simplifies things
so when you optimize over the space of
strategies turns into a much simpler
problem than we saw before
it's an unconstrained problem it's an
unconstrained problem of theta which we
can attack directly with any like
off-the-shelf
in gradient based technique however
evaluating this objective function is
still sort of expensive it requires
computing the pseudo inverse of the
strategy but you can exploit the
strategy you can exploit the structure
like the diagonal structure of the
matrix and evaluated efficiently so this
innovation you can scale matrix
mechanism up to domains of size about
ten thousand so beyond that point sort
of representing the workload or the
strategy in matrix form becomes a
challenge but ok so when you solve this
optimization problem for a well-known
workload like all range queries the
resulting strategy actually has some
nice interpretive structure which I'll
show here so we have two figures that
show two competing strategies for
answering range queries the one on the
left is the one that was found through
optimization and the one on the right is
a fixed strategy the hierarchical
strategy which is known to perform well
on answering range queries so the x axis
of these plots are the cells of the
domain and YX to the plots is like one
line per query and the blue represents
like what's the weight on that query is
so for the hierarchical strategy you
have one query that counts the total
number of records in the database and
then sixteen queries which count sixteen
queries that count like with sixteen
ranges this works well because you know
any range query can be expressed as a
sum of the locker bit log rhythmic
number of these things
in this do you who does one also try to
measure like individual like great ello
ya hilarity within those 16 blocks of 60
yeah so sorry there's an additional 256
queries both of these strategies contain
which are not plotted so every queries
that query every cell of the domain is
also there I meant to say that yeah so
yeah that's very important otherwise you
can't won't be able to answer all range
queries but the P identity strategy has
12 queries actually and the weight on
the queries is not like the same for all
cells it's sort of Center it looks more
like a hill I guess but the same
property sort of is there where if you
add up a small number of adjacent
queries it starts to look a lot like a
range query and so I guess the same
intuition applies so some concrete
numbers when you use this optimization
based technique you can sort of improve
the accuracy over these fixed strategies
well that the magnitude of the
improvement it seems to be constant so
when you compare it against the
hierarchical strategy which is known to
have like like logarithmic error the
improvement is usually around 1.8 and
does not grow with domain size and
beyond this largest domain that we
tested on you can't really run the
optimization because it's too expensive
so now I'm going to talk about you know
how you can get around the next
bottleneck which is representing the
workload and strategy and matrix form
but before I do if there's any questions
I'll go on so to get around the problem
of representing the workload in matrix
form if you have a multi dimensional
domain and your workload has structure
you can sometimes represent it more
compactly so consider this workload that
contains ten queries over a student's
database that encodes an empirical CDF
on a grade attribute for each sex so a
matrix form this is a 10 by 10 matrix
but because it has special structure you
can sort of factor it into a Cartesian
product of a sex sub workload and a
grade sub workload so that every query
from the original workload is just a
conjunction of one query from each sub
work
if you sort of vectorize these two sub
workloads you end up with a two by two
identity matrix and the five by five
lower triangular matrix and storing just
these sub matrices is sort of much more
efficient and you can if you take the
chroniker product of these two sub
matrices you can recover the workload
matrix for the original workload so with
using this idea you can sort of store
very large multi-dimensional workloads
pretty efficiently
when you apply this to the census
workload you can sort of reduce the size
or you can reduce like the amount of
memory you need to store it from
gigabytes or terabytes to like less than
a megabyte
so chronica products have a number of
nice properties that you can exploit to
run the matrix mechanism first it's
associativity so if you apply the
chronica product if you take the
Kronecker product of three or more
things it doesn't matter the order that
you do it if you want to multiply two
Kronecker product matrices you can do
that by multiplying just the factors of
the Kronecker product you want to take
the pseudo inverse you can do that by
computing the pseudo inverse of the
factors if you want to compute matrix
norms you can do it by just computing
the matrix norms of the factors it's
true for at least it's is true at least
for Frobenius norm maximum column norm
and like the sensitivity like the
maximum l2 norm for is true for at least
sensitivities and Frobenius norm switch
is what we need for matrix mechanism
optimization I'm not so sure if it's
true for all norms
so basically the key idea is that you
can perform all the computations you
need with respect to the factors of the
chronic or product without ever actually
materializing the matrix which is
interactively large so suppose we had a
chronic or product matrix how might we
hope to optimize how how much how might
we hope to find a strategy for that so
natural idea is to try to find a chronic
or product strategy as well so the what
we're assuming the workload is w1 krong
krong WD for a D dimensional domain so
it's easy to show using the properties
of chroniker products that the
sensitivity of the strategy and the
error profile decompose over the factors
in a nice way so the expected error the
expected matrix mechanism air also
decomposes over the factors which is a
nice thing
and additionally something that we
didn't talk much about but there's this
lower bound that says that it's a lower
bound on the minimum error you can
achieve under the matrix mechanism
called the SVD bound and that also
decomposes over the factors so what does
this mean this means if you had some
Oracle that could find the optimal
strategy for each sub workload and that
strategy attained the SVD bound then if
you take the Kronecker product of those
then you will construct a strategy which
attains the bound for the full Kronecker
product or cloade
and so if you wanted to minimize error
you don't have to solve one huge
optimization problem you can decompose
it into the independent smaller
optimization problems so this idea you
can sort of scale it up to domains of
size 1 million so this works if the
workload is a chronica product now I'd
like to go into like if it's a more
complicated workload although before I
do if there's any questions
so now suppose you have a more possibly
more expressive workload that contains a
union of K chronic or products this can
encode like an arbitrary collection of
like conjunctive counting queries
optimization over this space is a little
bit trickier and for that reason we
provide three different optimization
routines or look into three optimization
routines which primarily differ in sort
of the space of strategies which they
look over at a high level optimizing
over the space of all strategies is not
tractable but if you sort of look within
these smaller regions it becomes
somewhat tractable
the simplest thing you could do for
union of product workload is just take
each one and optimize it separately and
then stack those strategies into a big
matrix you can show that the error of
this strategy will be sort of bounded in
a nice way but it might not but and this
works well for some workloads but for
other workloads these strategies may
contain duplicate queries and then that
would if you ask the same query twice
under epsilon differential privacy with
a little fast mechanism it's sort of an
inefficient use of the privacy budget so
maybe there's it's not always the bet a
good thing to do another thing you could
do is try to find a single chronic or
product strategy that simultaneously
optimizes all of the workloads all the
sub workloads to do that you can notice
that the expected error still sort of
decomposes over the factors and so you
can evaluate the expected error
efficiently and because you can evaluate
the expected error efficiently you can
evaluate its gradient efficiently and
you can use gradient based techniques to
optimize it efficiently this works
better for this won't contain have the
duplicate query problem but it might
have other problems and it might not
work well for like workloads of low
dimensional marginals one other thing
you could do is optimize over the space
of marginal strategies and so marginal
looks like
so marginal can be expressed as a
chronic or product of between identity
matrices and total matrices where total
is a 1 by n matrix of ones and so a
collection of weighted marginals for d
dimensional domain can be written as a
union of two to the d chroniker products
where
yeah each Chronicle product is one of
the marginals so the strategy is
parametrized by a vector Boyd's theta of
length 2 to the D assigning a weight to
each marginal so is optimization so
optimization over this space would
require minimizing this objective
function first term is the sensitivity
of the strategy luckily that's easier to
compute it's just the sum of the fate
awaits second term looks a little bit
harder but because this strategy has a
nice structure you can actually derive
like an algorithm to compute a pseudo
inverse and ficient Li which doesn't
require materializing anything because
you can do that you can evaluate
expected error efficiently evaluate the
gradient efficiently and optimize over
the weights theta efficiently so we
provided three optimization routines for
optimizing over these types of workloads
and basically which one performs best
depends and complicated ways in the
workload but it since it's not looking
at the data you can try them all and see
which one gives you the best expected
there and then after that you can simply
run the matrix mechanism with this sort
of implicitly represented strategy
so Jerome's going to talk more about the
experiments but I'll just say one thing
about how close we're getting to optimal
so I focused mainly on epsilon
differential privacy but for epsilon
Delta privacy there are algorithms that
sort of yeah there's algorithms that can
find globally optimal strategies and
they're efficient and they run and
they're nice and you can still use sort
of some of these techniques for scaling
up in the epsilon Delta regime and when
you do you sort of get good results you
get close to the lower bounds and
epsilon differential privacy there's
still sort of a gap between what the
algorithms are achieving and what the
lower bounds are saying so this is
because the algorithms are sort of doing
local optimization over not all of the
strategies and also because maybe the
bounds for epsilon differential privacy
are looser so I think now I'm going to
turn it back to Jerome unless there's
any questions so we were using singular
value product of the singular values
which is one of the bounds that we'll
talk later maybe about other bounds like
geometry bounds I think they think if
your queries where this is a probably I
think that golf to most energy should be
also part of the product I think you can
show that not that yeah
I guess these collections of Kronecker
products of the tricky if it's a
collection party product then it
probably gets more complicated I have a
question for Brian and Jerome so in the
sort of application census or elsewhere
presumably once you have these noisy
answers you're doing this reconstruction
you're trying to find things that are
actually consistent with something real
data set if you're doing reconstruction
linearly if you're doing the
reconstruction is linear if I understand
correctly it's sort of doing part of
what Sascha described this projection
but maybe not all of it it's like you're
projecting on to rather than a polytope
like some kind of cone maybe or
something I think it's just based on
spacing and so I guess my my question is
you know in application I presume you're
because you're looking for like
eventually synthetic data maybe even
consistent with these things are
actually also doing the kind of
subversion possibly approximate of the
optimization that scishow had in his
life and I wonder if it's possible to
hold the benefits of that into the
optimization at all or there's any any
understanding of how we do that well I
think that's really hard I mean so so
there's a there's a there's a break like
there's a research paper on HTM which is
you know Ryan's work and we can do
reconstruction efficiently exploiting
the Kronecker products and that's just
sort of the least squares inference
reconstruction and there's the census
problem which is going to use some of
these techniques but does have to do
much more sophisticated post-processing
and I think it's going to be
really difficult to incorporate that
into the optimization objective I mean
it depends on the data I mean it depends
on the data I mean these but you
introduced added dependence with this
post-processing right so I don't see how
you can stay in the world of a of a data
independent optimization
yeah I mean I'm not sure either part of
it okay well let's look I mean let's
talk more about it I mean I mean but
yeah it's one of the things we have on
our open problem is that there's there
is we do this least-squares
reconstruction minimizing the l2 error
or we do strategy optimization with
respect to that reconstruction method
but then in practice we often do
something else afterwards and so there's
a mismatch between the post-processing
we do in practice and what we're feeding
into our optimization objective and that
you know we just don't know if that's a
big problem or maybe that's you know
perfectly fine in practice to do or if
you could if we could solve an
optimization problem that was you know
more faithful to what we're doing in
post-processing that would definitely be
a good thing and enough caution wise to
them to make it atención friendly and
this would be normalized then you
project it back
or which can be done yeah are you asking
if that would prefer that would perform
yeah we haven't yeah we haven't tried
that but no we haven't tried that we
haven't tried that I mean I guess I mean
my hunch is that so so but then you're
adding noise you know which is
proportional to the sensitivity of the
workload which is quite high and it's
hard for me to see the projection
removed we're removing all that noise
but we haven't tried it so I shouldn't
really say I mean I would sorry I mean I
guess it's a decent segue into that I
mean the best competing method that we
found from the ones that are you know
available that scale to this was
actually identity so I mean we're
improving identity by a factor of three
which you know there's a small constant
factor but then again that's why I was
so happy to hear this morning's talk
when I learned that it could cost a
thousand dollars to get an extra data
point and then reducing error by a
factor of three he could could really
save you a lot of a lot of money so so
so we have a way I mean so so this is
you know this is empirical work so it's
not a perfect optimization solution but
we have a way of finding what seem like
pretty good strategies for complex
workloads at scale there are you know
many other challenges so so first of all
I mean one of the things is that we can
optimize for domain sizes that are so
big that actually the bottleneck now
becomes materializing the data vector
and working with it and the other stages
of the mechanism even just adding noise
or doing reconstruction so we can't
scale to full geography not because we
can't optimize for the strategy but
because we can't do the other steps of
the algorithm now okay so the next step
as I mentioned census is that they're
sophisticated post-processing required
and there's a lot of effort going
going into that some of the interesting
questions that are arising that we can
use these techniques for is like how do
you do workload tuning what I call
workload tuning so for example those PL
94 statistics that are really important
what if I want to find a strategy that
dampens the error on those and let's
error be higher on other parts of the
workload we could do that by weighting
the workload queries and then solving
the optimization some of the questions
that they might ask if the census would
be you know maybe this sub workload that
corresponds to a table in SF 1 maybe
people don't use that so much maybe we
don't need to publish that if we weren't
going to publish that we take it out of
our workload and reoptimize would it
mean that error could go down elsewhere
on the stuff that people really use ok
so I think there's a lot of interesting
questions that we can start to look at
on how we tune the error of the
mechanism for the Census and even sort
of bigger picture than that what we
observed is that the whole publication
mechanism doesn't really make sense
anymore in the context of differential
privacy in the sense that like the SF 1
you know document describes these
particular contingency table type things
that are going to get published and
other things aren't published but what
we observed is that even when you work
with these tables obviously you can
compute by linear combinations a lot of
other statistics and in fact if you
decide you're gonna drop sub workload Y
in order in order to lower error on some
other tables what happens is that you
can still compute the queries in this
sub workload from the stuff that you
publish it's just that the error blows
up okay so now I don't know what I don't
an expert on how people use since the
census tabulations that are published
and if they ever compute linear
combinations from them and what their
expectations would be for the error of
those linear combinations computed from
stuff that's published but I think it's
something we have to be careful about
and it probably doesn't make sense to
think in this model of remove this table
from the Census
tabulations when you could reconstruct
it from other stuff that's published
that's like putting zero weight on this
work on this sub workload maybe we
should put a lower weight on it so that
the error doesn't blow up and people
aren't freaked out when they realize
that if you compute linear combinations
of some of the stuff that's published
the error is two orders of magnitude
bigger and we've seen we've seen you
know in some of the stuff that we've run
that that can happen one of the other
funny things that happens which is a
small open open problem for us is that
they need to the census needs to release
things at different times even if it's
computed on the same data set so for
example I think the PL 94 statistics may
need to be computed privately and
released early and then the rest of the
statistics are computed and and
privatized and released and so then we
have a question of sort of like a
subsequent we want to optimize for one
sub workload and then later conditioned
on the fact that we measured some stuff
and got these specific measurements and
released it like what new measurements
should we take and how should we
integrate them in order to make a
subsequent release computed over the
same data the nice feature of this of
this class of algorithms is that as I
said we can compute the error rates and
then they can be published they're not
sensitive but how how are they
communicated exactly to the stakeholders
that use this data I mean it's sort of
well-known that many consumers of census
data just use the data and pretend that
it's the true statistics and if
different statistics have complex error
profiles and things which they may
coming out of these mechanisms how do we
you know we could we can give them you
know measures of expected error but will
they use them and will they use them
correctly in something yeah question
tracking them in the math somewhere the
reconstruction involves this sort of
projection if you're doing this
least-squares reconstruction yeah right
and that's what these error that's what
the publishable error rates are about so
once we do the all the post-processing
and constraint satisfaction you write
the error will be different
it'll be data dependent it will be
harder to publish so so that's okay so
again there's sort of two types of
post-processing if I understand
qualitatively that are being discussed
one is this sort of least squares sub
projecting onto the subspace of because
things that are consistent with a data
set of unknown size and then possibly
you have other constraints yeah things
and is it the case that for that field
that least squares part we because it's
because the at least the reconstruction
is done by the multiplication by the
pseudo-inverse we actually can give like
per cell from your per query yes
absolutely yes error distribution yes
yes expected error is you know well the
distribution I'm not so sure about you
asked us this in the more layer as well
so that I'm not sure sir about the
distribution I mean the noise the noise
added to any work load query is like a
linear combination of independent
Laplace variables so you can analyze
yeah right
so yeah yes I think that's true
yeah so
is there like I mentioned this morning
that one of the secondary users of the
census data is fixing on other surveys
out there that needs to be sort of
adjusted and we're serving as guidance
for sampling for our second speaker is
there a level of aggregation and which
they committed so the noise varies
define level of aggregation here that
you have to be right I would assume and
is there can you give us a hint at which
level of application that becomes almost
negligible because the number of cases
in it up well I mean it depends I mean
it depends on epsilon and it depends on
the values that you're computing so I
mean even at the net you know at the
national level of geography which is
where we've focused our initial efforts
let's say I mean so you have 300 million
counts I mean the you know the total is
on the order of three million and
they're broken down into into these
demographic buckets but you still have
very rare combinations even at the
national level you don't have many
people that decided that are 115 years
old and our six races okay I mean that's
the account of that is it's still gonna
be under five and so the noise could
dwarf this you know signal it's hard to
say I mean but this is I mean I think
what you're getting is like can you give
me a hint of what like what's the
relative error rate gonna be like like
what's it gonna outside of the census
you would never find these cells I mean
it's in a regular survey it's so
unlikely that you would hit them yeah I
mean if you're looking at state popular
state population totals to do a portion
min at any reasonable epsilon the noise
will be negligible something like that
because those are those are big numbers
I mean
20 and then what why there weren't a lot
of people in 1929 20 census is like
close to the decision boundary it's like
oh yeah cuz yeah you did this work on a
persimmon
okay and there's their specials okay but
I mean but you can get very okay you can
get for most purposes for most problems
that you use state populations would be
the noise would be very small do you
think so it seems reasonable that or
purposes that progress talk about the
first level is actually more useful
yeah that's a that's an interesting idea
I mean the firt yeah yeah I mean it's an
idea I mean I haven't heard anybody
propose that because they I mean this
this I mean at that at that level you
still have negative counts alright
non-integral potentially negative counts
and if if Franco can do something useful
with those and and doesn't get upset and
I think in theory they could be
published but I mean there's a real fear
that going from from the nice clean data
that people are used to seeing to but
but in theory sure they that could be
published and it might it might be
useful especially because right the
effects of the second level of
post-processing are very difficult to
pin down yeah I mean it has no reason I
mean it's like a whole new kind of walks
I mean interesting yeah I have one other
question on the cliffhanger piece that
you were talking about earlier so you
said you focused on nation and state so
far and not necessarily touch the block
right it's still I mean it's still
really hard for us to run this run this
algorithm because when this ax data
vector has billion billions of cells
okay but we do have some work some
future work that Ryan's working on which
can do in France which which which
avoids materializing The X Factor and
can do global inference over
measurements taken over a bunch of
projections of the data vector on
subsets of attributes and so that would
be our our solution
but the pieces aren't fully put together
so we still have to do measurements
selection and we can do we can do
inference over these projections that's
what the forthcoming work and love to
talk about it another time okay so great
questions thank you we try to move
forward again
[Music]
okay so I was going to give you a little
bit of a workload tuning example so
remember I said that there's this like
important subset of the statistics that
make up the sf1 workload and you can
start to look at you know what would
happen is if I only had to release this
smaller set of PL 94 statistics I could
get like average per query error down to
three point nine one for some epsilon
epsilon one yeah Delta equals zero if I
optimize the entire workload so if
somebody tells me you really need to
support all this and I'm an optimized
total error over the whole workload on
average for this larger set of
statistics on average they're the
average per query error is 7 but it
happens to find a solution that in which
the air on the pill 94 statistics is
high and the error and the other things
are low okay so you might want to
rebalance things and you can you can do
this and so you know with with these
techniques you could you know give the
Census Bureau decision-makers a kind of
choice of where to set the weight on the
PL 94 statistics against against the
other sets of statistics and there's
obviously lots of important choices that
need to be made here I mean which are
essentially social choices that that
Census Bureau you know management needs
to make about which statistics matter
can tolerate more error and so on and
those are going to be very difficult
choices to make I think typically it's
very high up people the census that make
choices like that from from my
understanding but I think our goal is
algorithm designers to give them the
tools to accurately make those choices
and then you know yeah
or like caps people basically and people
in you know counts right the error is an
actual error they have yeah yeah yeah
like root yeah I think this is a root
mean squared error yeah
per query averaged over the set of
queries and just to get a sense of do we
like so I guess I mean just America came
up earlier like what what are the kind
of magnitudes of the counts and these
yeah that's right something you might
want to consider the PL 94
I mean PL 94 is like over 18 and then
broken down by all these raised
categories some of which can are pretty
rare because it's like all combinations
of races so you could have potentially
small counts but those but some of the
other the you know the counts of just
the individual races of over 18 people
and but then again this is down to the
block level you know in theory I mean
this is at the national level but you'd
want to be going down to the block so
it's it's a little bit hard hard to say
whether this is kind of like and again
this is for a particular epsilon but so
I'm trying to really just say this is
the trade-off that you could you could
clearly you know you bring down error a
lot without sack on the pale 94
statistic about sacrificing a lot until
you really need to bring until you
really want it to be low and then you're
going to sacrifice error on something
else
all right so I still have 21 20 minutes
okay all right
that's pretty good so I wanted to come
back to the data adaptive algorithms and
talk a little bit about the trade
trade-offs there I mean and this will
pick up on some of the empirical work
that I did with with colleagues a couple
years ago a flea talked about this at
Simon's actually about you know an
attempt if it steps towards a benchmark
and an observation that in the privacy
community especially when you're you
start to consider data adaptive
algorithms evaluation of those
algorithms is really hard to do and and
this came up during the demo about sort
of like betting first about public code
bases but then about benchmarks so I
want to show you some of the empirical
results of some of the trade-offs that
we witnessed when we when we consider
the performance of data adaptive
algorithms so what we did was we I mean
we observed that like this problem arose
in the in the machine learning community
as well that they you know years ago
observed that many papers were running
their algorithms on just a couple of
data sets you know classification
algorithms running on a couple of
well-known data sets which allows you to
do sound comparisons across algorithms
but also allows algorithms they're kind
of like over fit to the data and we
worried that that was happening at least
in the applied you know community that
everybody was using the same five data
sets and that there's actually a really
sinister thing you can that can happen
to researchers when when you're you know
you invent a clever new algorithm you
run it on the five data sets to see if
it works better than you know the
algorithm from the last paper and it
doesn't so you tweak the algorithm and
then you tweak it and then eventually it
beats the performance of the last paper
and I mean it's just sort of overfitting
a privacy algorithm to the to the data
when the algorithms are data adaptive
you can easily easily do stuff like that
so we tried to set out some principles
for evaluation and to vary the
properties of data sets and so these are
the properties that we varied we we the
domain size that we've talked about is
the length of like the frequency vector
the hrx vector what we call the scale
the total number of records in the
database and then
shape we called it of the distribution
okay and this is we were working at that
time in the low dimensional world so the
data is sort of like one-dimensional or
two-dimensional histograms and we wanted
to to to vary each of these properties
and see what happens and we considered a
range of data adaptive algorithms now
this one uniform is like it's just a
baseline it's a really naive algorithm
where you use the Laplace mechanism to
estimate the total number of records in
the database and then you just assume
that the distribution is completely
uniform okay
it's differentially private I mean it's
you know you can't say it's not a valid
algorithm but it's clearly not learning
a lot about the data so we have them mmm
and a bunch of other algorithms here
that are doing data adaptive things
adaptive grid based techniques into in
two dimensions there's even a Fourier
based technique that I think uses the
exponential mechanism to pick a K and
then drop and and only keep the top K
parameters and these that privately do
some data reduction and then do
measurement on top of it so there's a
bunch of algorithms I won't go through
all of them and the exact things they're
doing is not is not that critical
so the plots I'm going to show you you
so slightly a different error metric
than we're used to so we we were we
wanted to study scaled error because
we're changing the scale of the data a
lot and so we took the kind of like like
per query error that we've been talking
about and then we divided it by the
number of records and in whatever data
set we're considering so this you can
you can interpret this as error in units
of sort of like the population
percentage so if if the if you have a
thousand a population of a thousand an
absolute error of a hundred then you
know you're scaled absolute error is
point point one which might mean
something like if I want to detect
properties that are true in tempers in
populations of about ten percent then
this is like a lot of error as much air
as I could possibly tolerate and I
probably want the error lower okay so
here's what happens when we start to
look at the algorithm performance
these data dependent algorithms so we
have all these different interesting
algorithms on the x-axis and we have our
scaled error metric here so lower is is
better and the workload here where that
we're using is this prefix workload the
shape is given by some real data set up
the shape of the distribution domain
size is relatively small 4096
and it's a and and it consists of a
thousand individuals for epsilon point
one so we see that that that level of
error now if we look at the different
data sets what we do is we see a lot a
lot of dots and they differ a lot in
error like like at least an order of
magnitude maybe more all right so we see
that that these data adaptive algorithms
really have dramatically different
performance on different data sets and
you wouldn't know this ahead of time
right so we can then look at the
different algorithms and see how they
perform and we see that some are a
little bit more concentrated you know
and don't and are are adapting to the
data but it's not making as much of a
difference this is the uniform baseline
ok so air can be really low with uniform
presumably because the dad is really
uniform right but there's still a
significant spread and then what we want
so so so algorithm error very
significantly with data set shape I mean
from a practitioners point of view that
the challenge here is that you know I
mean one of our other observations is
it's not clear like really what the one
best algorithm is that you'd use all the
time and you can't pick the algorithm
you can't look at the data to pick the
algorithm you got to pick your algorithm
maybe maybe you can do it privately
right you might have to do it privately
was part per the point so then we can
also look at like well how does this
compare with our data independent
algorithms which you know we can always
run those now and and with though I
could have put those here as other
algorithms but because they don't vary
for their rates don't vary for data sets
I'll just look at them as like just a
a value here in a band sort of like a
good data independent algorithm which is
that some optimized hierarchy it's not
the full matrix mechanism and and and
just a naive die didn't have an identity
so that this is somewhere in the range
of what you're getting with the data
independent algorithm and look the data
dependent algorithms are doing much
better
okay at least for some regimes but and
in 2d that they seem to be doing you
know sort of even comparatively better
so data dependence can offer significant
improvements in error especially at the
smaller scale when the signal is less
either smaller scales or lower Epsilon
yeah I think cuz the data is well
approximated by uniform yeah it might
have been very very sparse though I mean
sparsity is well approximated by a
uniform right like lots of zeros now if
you increase the scale though here's
where you see the effect that we were
talking about earlier that the blue dots
are the ones that are better than the
data independent band and the gray ones
are kind of like in the middle and the
red ones are worse than that independent
being you see as essentially as the
signal gets stronger the data dependent
algorithms start underperforming the
data independent ones and I think this
is I think this you know can be
explained by the fact that there is bias
in these algorithms that doesn't go away
with increasing signal I think that's
one explanation here so we studied the
shore the consistency of these
algorithms and some of them are not
consistent in the sense that as epsilon
goes to infinity you don't get the true
answer out of these algorithms because
they're either imposing some structure
on the data or doing some something else
okay so
so there's more if you ever if you want
to read the paper there's more there's a
lot more in the the practical evaluation
I think the high level bit that I wanted
to share is just that this low signal
and high signal for the data in
dependent algorithms from again from a
parent practitioner point of view like
it it becomes hard to pick the right
algorithm because you you you know the
performance is a little bit you know
it's quite variable based based on the
on the data data sets and so we we did
some work and others have done done some
done work on privately choose private
algorithm selection which can be
important in the context of these data
dependence algorithms okay so I'm
actually I'm amazingly and we had
questions and everything just I think
this can be sort of an informal rehash
of open problems that Sasha can
contribute to as well but I mean I'll
just say that you know when this this
scalable matrix maximum what you call
the high dimensional maximum Matrix
mechanism which I think John was one we
heard early versions of this talk and
said is this really high dimensional
it's not that high it's sort of like
medium high dimensional and but it
exposes that the next bottleneck we have
to deal with is just materializing the
data vector that we need to avoid that I
mean there are other albums that avoid
that like I mentioned Perez and and dual
query and we're working on some
techniques based on graphical model
inference to avoid that I already
mentioned that there's this you know
potentially troubling mismatch between
the optimization metric that we we can
finally optimize it but it's really not
exactly what we do in practice because
we do this more complicated
post-processing I don't know if they're
interesting theory questions there but
it would be nice to like bound how bad
you know I don't know how how suboptimal
our strategies could be in the presence
of more sophisticated post-processing
maybe or something like that
I think the empirical work is a big
qualification of our empirical study was
really on low dimensional
stuff and we we're poised now to do more
more of a kind of benchmark study of
higher dimensional algorithms we do I
don't understand I can't say that I
understand well this trade-off between
data independent and data dependent
algorithms in the case of the high
dimensional stuff we're starting to look
beyond linear queries if I can if I can
mention that in this tutorial on linear
queries I'm a database guy so we're
trying to build systems that could
answer SQL queries and there are a
number of SQL queries that are not
linear and it's not clear what the
exactly the right approach there is I
mean one of our initial approaches is to
sort of like try to transform the data
in a way that kind of like in caps lets
the non-linearity and create like what
we call like a materialized view of the
data and then do linear measurements on
it I mean nother thing you can do is
just do linear measurements and then do
some lot and then produce a histogram
and then compute something that's
nonlinear on it like a median is a
nonlinear query right you could just
compute it noisy histogram and then
compute the median the other SQL queries
that where weird things happen is like
counting the distinct elements is
nonlinear thing we call the double group
I like if you do a group by you get
counts for groups those are linear those
those correspond to like linear counts
but if then you do a group by on that
thing you get some non nonlinear
behavior and people do do do do that
it's like a kind of like count of the
frequencies of things starts to look
like and I'm going to query in some self
joins and things like that joining a
table with itself produces
nonlinearities so that's the those those
are kind of like odd really odd queries
from the standpoint of the techniques
that we've talked about today and it's
not not clear how to how to handle them
so I'll stop there and maybe open it up
to Sasha or anybody else questions or
other open problems
[Applause]
right there are lots of questions to
explore so definitely going beyond
counting queries and linear queries is
an interesting problem I think in
practicing in theory but uh me mention
just a couple of the ones I sort of
mentioned during the talk so we saw a
lot about optimizing your your your
algorithm based on the queries you're
trying to answer given the gene all the
queries in advance I think you'll be
interesting to try to do this sort of
online as you're getting the queries try
to keep adapting to the queries that
you're saying right now I kind of know
right so the really simple mechanisms
like Gaussian and Laplace noise kind of
trivially handle where is that arrive
online because you you just need an
estimate on the sensitivity and you know
a worst-case estimate on that private
multiplicative weights can also work
online and there's this media mechanism
which is not really efficient but I
think we don't really know how to try to
adapt to do queries that we're seeing in
an online manner as you're getting the
queries so this is sort of some mix of
like online algorithms and like these
differential privacy questions what else
do they have problems right and so this
problem which I has sort of have
algorithms that perform optimally for
sort of any query workload and databases
of any size we have some partial results
with sort of weak optimality guarantees
for root mean squared error and almost
no understanding of this question for
worst case error is I think we tried a
while ago with kunal and we didn't get
very far in sure there many other great
open questions of course handling like
three four five way marginals with more
efficient algorithms
frustrating problem for a while many
questions were other open problems that
anyone wants to volunteer comments
so um
I guess I was thinking of the sort of
discussion of how independent algorithms
have you can completely describe their
distribution for data dependent
algorithm just I guess I was wondering
if for something like the projection
mechanism or things that can be
interpreted as some kind of like maximum
likelihood estimate given the noisy
answers of giving some kind of like
instants dependent error bound I mean
something maybe like better than just
the you know reporting the calculations
you did about them here see like
something more precise we have to depend
on the database I guess it would be
private right necessarily I mean you
could imagine something that's based on
the output okay I see let's say you know
your inputs are the original noisy
things and the projected IC value maybe
you have a sense of how objection
operation will likely with like some
sense of a sampling distribution of the
error is opposed after with this book
processing yeah I understand the
question correctly so we do a little bit
of that in the beta model of a session I
big indie annals of stats paper right we
actually do kind of post-processing
you're doing we're projecting into
certain polytop off the acceptable
the criteria there was the existence of
the Emmeline because if you have used
the the noisy degrees without this
additional post-processing and the post
processing has to be done kind of in
this projection way that you were
describing but the criteria there was
the existence of the Emily for these
models and we're looking at and there
are some consistency resolves that they
were proving there so I think maybe
that's we're asking for this was very
specific for a very just her - Randy
long right that's right I guess I wanted
like we find out a little more exact you
mean but but like the projection
mechanism that's lesser described like
is the MLE like you know you're adding
Gaussian noise so like the least-squares
projection is actually the maximum
likelihood estimate for the original - I
was like can you the error distribution
itself is like highly dependent on like
what data set you started with and also
on like what point you're projecting and
so I'm just I don't know if maybe you
you might know like sort of ways of
getting confidence intervals or
something from these projection type
things of these Emily type things well I
mean I can say no a general solution I
know that we look at this in this
particular solution where basically I
know that I you know um I should say I'm
talking to you because we were getting
asymptotic consistency results here
exactly the same thing I mean we were
getting an Emily but then you still have
to because if it's a slightly different
distribution that you're getting that
ordinarily you would you have coarse it
see results but it's possible to do it
can we is this a general technique I
think maybe there is but we have not
considered it in other settings well I
guess a point is one for some of these
things when couldn't in principle
consider sort of you know Bayesian
approaches of get to getting a sort of a
distribution over plausible original
data sets I'm guessing that it's
currently out of reach for the kinds of
settings that Durham cares about
computational at least in principle one
could imagine doing that in this er
practice question for Jerome and Ryan I
don't know if there's a short answer to
this but for the census workloads did
you try both you know epsilon 0 and
epsilon Delta like get Laplace and
Gaussian noise and and sort of perfectly
comparable values of course if it's
apples and oranges a little bit but
roughly comparable values is there a an
enormous benefit from using say you know
the CDP and Alice it's like you hug
after annoying me I don't think we try
to try that we've mostly been focused on
epsilon 0 DP and so we were always
running the optimization on that it was
actually only coming here that we we
decided to run and so I think I think
the the trade-off that we will get will
get closer to optimal strategies for you
know our optimization metric and then
we'll face the constants that come to
the couch on noise the strategies will
be like also just way better because
you know you're gonna be the sensitivity
of these vectors will be you know using
l 2-norm instead of L 1 which will be
make a big change for a lot of
presumably make a big change
yeah we haven't tried it yeah we have a
trader I mean yeah so let's say for its
you know for but you have to pick a
delta to say I'm not mistake for the
[ __ ] for the census because they are
they don't like couldn't have
conservative for reasons that make a lot
of sense but you know in general
application what I might imagine many
people would be comfortable with the
moments accountant slash CDP view of
what's going on here and yeah we should
try that it is listen you P you don't
have to big Delta yeah I'm just curious
if it'd be like orders of magnitude or
just you know factors of force yeah we
should try that